Hello.
I recently finished my biggest project
yet all animated tour of the history of
writing, but before we move on, I wanted
to take some time to cover two things.
One,
what we missed and to what we got wrong,
but I think there's someone better
for this job. The narrator herself.
Hi, I'm Jessica. Uh,
hopefully you already know me
as the voice of thoughts pill.
If you haven't had a
chance to catch that yet,
I highly recommend it and there's
a lot of great stuff in there.
I'm also the girl who was about to start
showing you how your life is made of
code over at comp comp,
but a thoughts pill. Yeah,
this was really a labor of
love and as it stands now,
we put about 10 to 15 minutes into this
film for every single person that's
watched it so far. So that's a
very personal connection for us.
99% of that as Josh. Ah, he did all
of the art, the animation, the music,
the scripts for the animated history
of writing, even recorded himself,
narrating the whole thing
over and over and over again.
But he ended up liking my version
better. And so, yeah, I'm the narrator.
Um, one thing that that
meant was that, uh,
there were a lot of parts
where you actually hear the
like languages that we're
talking about and I don't
actually speak those languages.
So we ended up cutting that. Um, but let's
talk about what else we didn't get to.
So,
uh,
in the beginning we had pre history and
the cave rushes over so much of history
and speculation about proto writing and
we kind of used it as a metaphor just as
much as an actual historical place.
And when you leave the ancestral
cave and inter the civilized world,
we need Loga graphs.
The original plans had us pan from the
dark cave up to the wellness world above
once we were up in those cities,
we profile a handful of them.
Some of them like the Minoans and creek
just barely get a mention later on in
the series.
And if you start digging,
it's not hard to find other early scripts
that we skipped all together like LMI
or Cypriot or is that the tech and
the questionable unsolved mysteries of
prehistoric writing like Vincia
symbols and into scripts and whatnot,
integrating those really
started to sidetrack the story.
So after going down the
birth of writing hitlist,
we ran into that early tension
between meaning and sounds. Well,
we originally had a second tension
for these cradles of civilization.
What is writing for these symbols helps
civilizations expand. CARF propaganda,
track their goods,
time after time.
These old loba graphs
are about kind of boring,
mundane things like counting goats and
barley or that king so and so ruled for
such and such a long time and smoked
all of his enemies throughout his many,
many days of being awesome. But, uh,
fortunately for the
romantic and all of us,
some writers were capable of turning
even these early symbols into verbal art.
The most famous early
example is Gilgamesh.
A story that top the cuneiform bestseller
list for over a thousand years,
which is really,
uh,
we ended up folding the idea behind
this tension into the flexibility and
creativity versus consistency.
Tension that shows up when
we talk about the manuscript.
It was particularly sad
for us to cut Gilgamesh.
It's a story that reminds us that
civilization and its innovations team,
the savage human,
but at a cost nature is wild
and mortality as elusive,
but civilized humans can live on through
their physical achievements during
their lifetimes. It was sort of an
uncanny prism for thermoses warning.
In the introduction. Oral ideas
are embedded, but thoughts pill.
The technology of writing DM beds you
and offers some degree of immortality to
your thoughts and actions.
Okay. Onto rebus writing,
we talked a lot about taking a character
and using it for it sounded like value.
Of course,
there's another option beyond using the
same character for smaller or larger
chunks, and this will apply to later.
Innovations to the character can change.
And the process.
Anyone who's ever learned to read another
writing system has the experience of
painfully copying every little nook,
cranny and Seidler of assemble before
finding out which strokes are meaningful
and which ones can be left out.
Add service to an I and
you're fine believe that.off
the top and things kind of
get weird unless it's in Turkish and
then they're entirely different letters.
Although it's a crucial step in
learning to script like a native.
The stroke game is something
that's obvious from the inside,
but can really perplex outsiders.
I contrasted using characters
for syllables and cuneiform
versus continents in
Egyptian.
Hieroglyphs to technical
details got cut out here first.
The writing direction,
we later mentioned when we get to China
that were words go and where they stop
matter in writing.
We were going to be a bit more specific
for hieroglyphs showing you that when
you're reading hieroglyphs
you read into the bodies.
Some materials will
tell you into the faces,
but even when there's no face around body
parts still face against the direction
you're reading unpacked.
And for cuneiform we had a whole section
on Josh's favorite cuneiform court.
That's right. He's got a favorite,
those Sumero grams and it came to grams.
That evolved as the script was
passed around the Fertile Crescent.
It didn't really fit well into the script,
but it became its own video and this clip
from that video made its way into the
documentary when we talked about how
the early choice to use syllables shaped
every later version of the script.
So there was also an important question
to ask here and when they hit through
other close to home,
is it surprising or novel that the
leader scripts around the Mediterranean,
you know the ones that lead
to our alphabet end up using
consonant segments like
the Egyptians had already been doing in
an ask it whatever onto determinative.
This revolved around Chinese and
spills over into the part on Maya,
but it's really worth taking some time
to read up a bit on how this happens in
other scripts and how
they use determinitive.
Egyptian and cuneiform
actually use them too.
It's one of the reasons each section
in this story is structured a specific
development in the history of writing.
We're looking at these as common solutions
to problems faced by multiple scripts,
not just cultural teams.
Uh,
the other reason is we wanted to jump
around to exotic locales because traveling
is fun, even if it's just in a
cartoon. Anyhow, a determinative,
I lumped classifiers and
determinative and radicals together.
If you're interested in putting those
concepts apart and digging deeper,
I recommend starting with this paper on
the use of complementation in the Maya
script.
Basically,
it argues that we should use the term
determinative for a meaning sign that
helps us choose the spelling of a word
and classifier for our meaning sign that
tells us which category
the word belongs to.
Another thing when it comes
to China is stroke order.
The way of writing the characters. Josh
actually thinks this is so important. He,
uh, wants to write a whole separate
script and do a different video for it.
I know he recorded a rant
a really long one. Uh,
I don't know if he's planning on
animating it, but if you're interested,
you might want to let
them know. Oh yeah. Uh,
both Chinese and Maya remind us that sound
writing isn't the right way to write.
Be Era of history doesn't inevitably
point from meaning to sounds.
Inventing phonetic characters does not
mean that you abandoned your lower graphs.
Innovations and traditions can hold hands
and it mixed writing system like this.
Uh, and a lot of you picked up on
that but I wanted to make sure that we
specifically put that out there.
So from Central America we flew to Egypt,
which reminds me we're going to stand
by this title for now. Provocative,
yes, but not misleading. Uh Oh.
I will say one other thing about Egypt
by focusing on the trajectory to our
alphabet.
We totally missed out on another thread
that was in the initial story plans from
Sogdian to Mongolian.
I don't know about you guys,
but I personally would love
to have seen what kind of fun,
crazy characters Josh came up
with for covering Mongolian.
I'm getting Iskcon is one of my favorites.
Gene just however you want
to say his name, the same.
Oh man came up later too when we didn't
get to tell the stories about to carry
on and Ethiopic Alpha Cilla Berries,
although at least the Abita did squeeze
in there for one quick little exercise
at the end of India.
Speaking of Alphabets, uh,
I really liked the way Greece turned out.
Josh wants you to know,
he thinks it's a bit funny that the Greek
is that the Greeks and thoughts pill,
no etic stuff that wasn't common.
Iem acknowledged in ancient times.
You're a new friend friend talks about
Troy and the ancient Greek script that
actually predates the alphabet,
but he stopped short of calling
it linear B. Truthfully,
it's already an anachronism that he knows
about this script in the first place
and can mention how it works.
Since early documents written in the
Greek alphabet suggest that Greek
civilization fell into
complete illiteracy.
Essentially they all forgot how to write
and that brings us to an interesting
idea that actually didn't make the cut.
It's what I mentioned to Josh when he
shared his outline the first time people
losing writing.
This animation looks at writing as
a of inventions and improvements.
But what about the steps backwards and
sideways and even away from writing?
What impact did those have on writing
to get a grasp of the strangeness here?
Think about the use of
pictures and nonverbal layouts
of information on websites.
And what other ways do we supplement
or move away from the written word? Uh,
speaking of Alphabets,
we brought up the correspondence between
symbols and sounds and then the birth
of the Latin alphabet.
We originally wanted to go down the road
a bit and discuss historical spelling,
English and French spelling, guarded
tutorials for this. But over time,
the alphabetic principle can get a little
lax since a word might be spelled the
way it was when this system started,
even when its pronunciation is modernized
and flagrant disregard for the ancient
tongue.
Uh,
the example we plan to show for this was
from Irish and it went like this, right?
The word who are, yeah,
that's right. Uh, oh.
And yeah, we totally hear you. That
we did not cover uppercase, lowercase.
It's definitely a topic
that we want to go into,
but we didn't have time to fit
it into thoughts, pill. Um,
it really is worth a video of its own.
Okay.
So on to ob dots that the pirates trader
was a reminder that writing back in the
day wasn't some guy grunting
and making crude marks.
There was already an entire industry
behind each stroke of the pen or press of
the stylists into clay.
Think of all that it took to make an
ancient Mediterranean text harvesting to
book Paris, cutting the stocks
open and cutting it into strips.
Loing layers of those strips together
crosswise to make a sheet using well
developed trade networks to distribute
that paper overseas. It goes on and on.
The Phoenician merchant was a mental
prick to help remind you of the obvious
that writing leans on the development of
civilizations, the materials, resources,
trade routes.
It was also a way of getting you to
think of the economy of writing and
extending that to get you to ask
questions about how the economy shaped the
look, the use, and eventually
even the dispersal of writing, uh,
writing on the horizontal Recto or
front of the book pirates instead of the
vertical verso of the proprietress or
how ancient letter shapes changed from
chiseled to inky. On the Mediterranean
map, we see some scripts pop up.
One of them is in Iberia.
Well,
the rather unique Paleo
Iberian scripts are semi Cilla.
Barry's derived mainly from Phoenician
with some possible Greek influence.
Okay.
Time is getting away from us here.
I promise I'll just
mention a few more goodies.
In Phoenicia we tackled matrass and
pointing and originally asked a bunch of
questions for you to ponder
what's better in a writing system.
Optional extras like fouls added
in only when you really need it.
That set things straight or a system that
demands clarity even when that clarity
is a peripheral less. Um hmm.
Let's skip ahead to king. Say Dawn,
who's heard exotic tales
of the west of India.
This was a nod to the concept of
India as the West in East Asia,
the most well known example
of this reference is in the
Chinese novel journey to
the West.
But if you start reading,
you can dig up a whole history of
relationships. Here's another hint.
The Go Juwann of Japanese Kona have
an order strikingly reminiscent to the
layout of Devanagari used to
write Sanskrit. Uh, yeah. Okay.
So in Korea,
uh,
since feature alphabets get treated
as a separate type of writing system,
we thought it was worth
including in our major moments.
Some of you definitely disagreed.
Korea is also the location
of our technical error
that just stands out like a
sore thumb. Josh switched the
name of two of his sheep keys.
So these Korean characters got
swapped out in the final cut.
So after Korea we end with a look back.
But our idea of a look ahead at the
future of writing didn't make it.
What about changes in how we communicate
like pictograms or signs or relying
more on videos and images to communicate?
What about emojis?
Are we communicating
better info faster now?
So writing is just less necessary and
it's not doing the same job at once.
Debt West Cecil shared a similar
thought in his talk about the future of
language and it's been on our minds.
Oh and a do different scripts do
different things to our brains.
How does growing up with a different
writing system impact anything else?
Like the way you think about language or
ideas or even the way you store words?
Uh, finally, and Josh has been trying
to get me to stay quiet about this,
but I want to tease and say that there
were a decent number of Easter egg
scattered around the world he built.
I don't know if all of them showed up
in the final camera angles and whatnot,
but a lot of them do. MMM. Okay.
So that wraps this up.
I just want to thank you guys so
much for taking this journey with us.
I'm really glad I got roped into this.
I was very hesitant at first.
I said they're not going to want to hear
a different voice on the channel. Um,
but you guys were so welcoming and your
feedback in the community has just been
fantastic.
If you're interested in seeing more of
me or learning how your everyday life is
made up of code or hopefully both,
uh,
you can check out my
new channel comp chomp,
Josh is going to be over there animating,
making stuff fly around the screen and
coming up with a lot of the cool topics
that we do on that channel as well.
Uh,
and if you have it already
and you definitely should
subscribe your native lane
and encouraged Josh to keep
doing videos about language.
Otherwise I'm going to steal him and he's
only going to be doing computer stuff.
Now. I know he's really busy with classes
and has some other projects, but um,
your encouragement when it's genuine, it
really matters. And, uh, even if you know,
you just had him get some
quicker sketchier art out
there. The videos are fun.
Anyway, subscribe for language and now
subscribe for programming language.
Fun to jump.